i'm radoslav georgiev it's really hard
to pronounce eastern european name so
just call me
rado it will do uh i'm the
ceo ceo of a software development
company where we
mainly do django and react this is like
our bread and butter
so but we're here for something
different we want to talk about django
so
let's see by raise of hands who here is
working with django
daily
all right and now the people who are
working
weekly but just weekly not daily
they have to touch django from time to
time all right so pretty pretty good
audience
uh i hope this is going to be
interesting and actually
uh and resourceful for you so what do we
want to achieve
first thing we want to enable
productive django teams as mentioned in
the keynote this morning
it's really hard when you have like a
big
software and it's not using a popular
framework and it's really hard to set up
in bootstrap it's really hard to get
people to contribute because there's a
high barrier to actually running any
piece of code
so this is one of the things that we
want to do when we're developing django
applications and we're developing django
applications that are going to be used
for like
next five to ten years and we need to
support it and
we need to add features remove features
fix books
uh write bugs and so on
which is the same thing we want to have
a stable software
and we don't want to introduce random
bugs which we are going to see
in the presentation and also avoid any
kind of needless abstraction
uh avoid this thing where someone writes
a
a really nice piece of abstraction and
only he or she
understands it and then everyone else
who has to touch this code is like oh
just ask him or better make him or her
right
this piece of call because we have a
needless abstraction so
this we are going to try to eliminate
this
and the most important thing for me is
to have a repeatable pattern
and this applies not only to django but
applies generated to software
development
the best thing we can do is to have a
repeatable pattern of adding new
features
or fixing existing features or removing
existing features we don't want to
invent the wheel every time we have to
do
something new and this is what we're
trying to achieve today
all right so uh the main question
because i'll need an entire day
of djangocon to talk about the entire
topic because django is a big framework
so the question that we're going to
focus on today is where to put business
logic
in django and the first thing that we
need to ask ourselves is
how do we define this uh mythical beast
called business logic
any suggestions how do you define
business logic in less than five
sentences
[Music]
yeah i'll try so for me this is
everything that's uh specific to the
domain of the software that we're
writing
if we're writing a software that deals
with hotel management and booking
everything related to how we book and
manage a hotel is
as a business logic or
more generally speaking the the
constraints and the relationships in our
code
every time you see an if and this if is
not in a utility method that checks some
strings
it this if probably is a business rule
that needs to be applied in the software
so
almost everything that's not framework
or utility
is business logic it's the thing that
we're writing the software
about all right
so let's talk about boxes i really love
this um
how to say example framework or
frameworks in general
they give us boxes and those boxes are
places where we can put our code in
we have boxes and in django we have
several boxes
where we can put and structure our
application
and actually put our business logic
because our business logic is like 80
of the entire code base the rest is
views models and so on
and the very first box that people
actually hit
when writing django is the models and
i think models are like the big and
integral
integral part of django and
we kind of use django because it has a
really nice aura
so models they defined the so called
data model
we have like uh entity relationship
diagram
people love creating those diagrams i
don't know why
and we had to turn this er diagram into
models
with the proper relationships with the
proper constraints
as i said there are very important part
of django
and they define the relations that later
we're going to use in so-called business
logic
and models can have properties and
static or class methods
and we usually start putting some small
part of our business logic
in those model properties or in those
model
methods either class metastatic method
or
instance method and the thing where
where people start tripping over and
things start to get like bad is when
they start put
putting business logic in the safe
method so this is
a lot of tutorials do this it's like you
refine save method and you start adding
code there
you start adding tasks that send email
and you run a test suit where you
bootstrap
a lot of users and you have production
settings on your local machine and while
running your test suit you send emails
to randomly generated emails
which is pretty fun experience so models
let's see an example uh let's let's have
a course model that defines a start and
end date
so business logic can be this thing here
has started or has finished it depends
on the now
we have some get now that returns the
proper date in the proper time zone
and we say true or false the course has
started or cause
have uh has finished and we returned
this in some api
and the ui updates accordingly to this
so this is an example of business logic
is
pretty straightforward and is the right
place to add it
another thing that models allow us to do
is to define custom validation
because sometimes the validation needs
to be expressed as a python code
and not just as a database constraint
and this custom validation is
usually written in the clean method and
uh
the thing that we usually do is we
define safe call full clean
not to forget to call it in the other
place
and raise validation errors if
something's wrong
and this is also a good place to put
your business logic
it's like additional validations and
models
keep those two things together
properties and additional validation
and this is kind of ugly and it's
according to me and this presentation
not the right way to do it
so don't try to read the code i've just
pasted some call from a system that we
use
for our our
learning management system that we use
for the courses uh
when you create the course you need to
generate weeks for the course because we
organize content around weeks
and this sudden list starts to feel
heavy because i have
a really core thing defined in my model
safe
it's going to work but it's not going to
scale and
the thing is if i put it here
i have to put everything else related to
this here
tasks more logic whatever you imagine
related to course creation and for me
models should take care only of the data
model have
simple properties and define extra
validation and this is where we draw the
line
we don't do like everything is going to
be in the model
we just don't do this because then we
get a fat models
which don't scale very well because you
have to put everything there
so business logic in models three simple
rules that we have
it's like it's okay to do it in
properties
and we'll see later when it's not okay
it's
okay to define additional validation and
clean
and it's totally not okay to start
adding a bunch of code in your safe
method because you want to keep
some kind of separation of concerns
models
data model not business logic all
carry on the next integral part of
django is
views and apis i'm going to talk about
apis using rest framework
for us rest framework is django
you install it as a separate library but
it's the go to library that you're using
when doing apis the same thing applies
for views i said you don't have enough
time to
cover everything so the views and the
apis there like the http interface to
the rest of the world and they call
things
on the inside and
can hold business logic which is usually
shown in tutorials we'll take a look at
your tutorials it's like
if you don't do it in the models you're
going to do it in the post method of
your
api or or your view of your view
uh and as i said i will focus on apis so
this is copy pasted example from rest
framework which again
is a great framework and
the thing that's being defined here is
two apis that
do a crud over
some snippet model and even more if you
scroll a few scrolls down in the
tutorial
you're going to end up with this example
this is a
model view set that needs two things to
work a
a query set and a serializer
you can then use a router and you have a
crude api
over a model in
around five lines of code which is
pretty neat
it looks really good but then
what's happening do you know
three lines of code where in the three
lines of code
is your model being created for example
if you use the create
api who knows who can shout raise a hand
where in the serializer
so what happens you hit this api
the create model mixing from the rest
framework create method this code
the serializer is instantiated and
validation is run
and then the snippet serializer method
create this code
so we have three lines which look neat
for an api
but then the heavyweight needs to be
done by the
serializer and it's a third-party
library
thing which is really nice but it has to
create our objects
so if you want to put additional
business logic around creating some
something which is like almost all the
cases
this is really good for hooking people
up
look three lines of code crot we're
awesome framework
but then reality comes and you have to
do
five additional things when you're
creating a snippet
and then you go to the serializer and
you really find create method and you
start
dumping code there so let's talk about
serializers they're like
really really great and i wish
some somehow forks them out of rest
framework as a separate
library because the plain serializer is
really nice
model serializers django related plane
you can use them for
a lot of things so they're great to
transform python and
rm objects to json or whatever you want
xml and so on json is the usual thing
they are great to do the other thing
transform json coming to an api
and make it python data or even
rm object data make the query for you
and this is where we draw the line two
things
that stereotypes are really good at and
should be used
it's okay the last thing that people
often do
is to use serializers to create objects
it's like you define create and you have
like 500 lines of a crate
in a serializer and it's again a
separation of concerns thing
serializers the first two things
not the third thing it's not a
serializer's job to create your objects
it's your job to create your address
it's it's not the api's job to create
your objects
deep in some abstraction because we have
three lines of code
it's again your job all right so here's
an alternative then
you say rado okay i won't do it in the
safe method i won't do it in the
serializer but i will
definitely do it in the post of the api
which is also shown in a lot of
tutorials again don't
just dump a cold dump which
not even sure if it's correct we need to
refactor this but
this is what people also do
and this may be okay
if you think hard about it there are not
a lot of bad reasons to do it
and then again business logic and apis
is great until you need
to do the same business logic
you know you know we in a view
you have you have api for react and you
have some
old django view with html you have to do
the same thing
or you have to do it in a task
you have salary and you have to do the
same thing in a task
or you have to do the same thing in a
command
or you have to do the same thing
somewhere internally in your system
because
you have a chain of automation where
snippets or courses are being created as
part of other
flows and then we have
five places where we can do the same
thing
and the the bad approach here
is to start instantiating the api
to use the post methods in order to have
the same business logic
it's like red flags everywhere so
if you have only api uh it perhaps it's
okay if you have something very simple
perhaps it's okay to use
the model view sets of the rest
framework but we're talking about
projects that evolve
and scale with time and we need to be
flexible and we need to have teams
working on them
so this is not the box we're looking for
none of the things that i've shown so
far it's not the box that we need for
business logic
and often time we need more boxes
how to say it's wrong to assume that
all the things that django's giving us
are all the things that we have to use
and we try to put and we try to put
things to boxes where they don't belong
and when we do this often and
times go and time time goes by then we
end up with a bad design and then we end
up with random bugs and then we end up
with
unmaintainable code base because you
have a serializer
somewhere in your code base and you just
add a
simple property because your api needs
it
and you break five other apis because
five other apis are
using the same serializer and you don't
know that and
such things can be really really bad
developer experience so
we need a new box and this box is like
it's pretty simple uh a personal note on
obstruction
i don't feel really good when i have
three lines of code
and then 100 lines of obstruction
underneath it
that creates my object in the database
and
then i'm not sure what i have to
redefine i have to read the rest
framework code which is
nice done it many times but
i don't feel good when there's a lot of
layers of abstraction between
me and the orm which actually saves
the object to the database that's why i
don't like the model view sets or the
generic apis or views at all
there they should not be used unless you
have a really simple project
and on the other hand sometimes when
reading
things from the database you have
additional business logic
you have to do filtering based on other
objects in the database are filtering
based on your internal business logic
it's not like
just a list api view which dumps all
objects
define a pagination and we're done
it also happens we can get away with
abstraction here
but when the thing comes that we need
more flexibility and control
we have to again redo everything so
those are the existing boxes that
django's giving us
models views templates tasks
for with salary for example and
none of those boxes are suitable for
heavy business logic
i don't have time to show you some nice
uh template examples where you put a lot
of business logic in templates
and you do a lot of queries and you
can't
understand from where these queries are
coming but templates are like the worst
idea to add business logic
just no time for this so
the thing that we're doing at uh our
company since we're writing django every
day and
all of our clients our projects we're
using django
we're developing a style guide which we
are constantly debating
and updating because we want to have a
repeatable pattern
of writing django apps that is nice easy
to use it's not a burden
it's not something that you have to
learn as an abstraction
and that's why i'm here actually to
share
where we put our business logic
and the first new box that we introduce
which is the fancy name service
is called services it's like services.py
module
in your app each app has a services py
you can split the module inside however
you want
but this is the general unit that
deals with the business logic meaning
creating rm objects doing additional
stuff with those with those rm objects
calling color services uh and so on and
so forth we'll see an example in a
second
and the other thing that we're doing
with the services is we have
like a specification it's a keyword only
function
with type annotations which helps a lot
for document documenting what you're
actually doing with this
with this function uh speaks the domain
language
can call other services can call other
tasks it's like all the heavy lifting
is isolated in a core part called
services and
selectors we'll see them in a second and
the rest of the django
is either communicating with the service
like apis or being communicated from the
service like
oram uh yeah as i said can handle
everything that needs to be done and it
works mostly and mainly with models
because django without drm it's like no
use to use django at all
so here's the good stuff here's the
example pretty simple service
code create user as you can see we're
doing the
we are doing the keyword only thing
which means you can't call a service
with 10 positional arguments and wonder
which is which or what is what you have
to pass
the keywords by name explicitly
this is the first thing the second thing
is we have type annotations
what are the arguments what is the
return type and
even if we don't use my pie yet it's
it still needs something for django
support it's really nice because
it lets you understand what the service
is doing it lets you
jump around the project i see that this
is returning a user model and i want to
see what the user model is
i hate some combination in my editor or
ide and i jump there and i see
and i return it's really really nice and
what's happening inside this
i create a model and i go to other
services
the first one creates a profile the
second one
calls a task again we don't have time to
talk about services and salary tasks
because there's a lot of interesting
stuff there but
the thing that we do is we wrap all of
our tasks
in a service because this way is
isolated nicely
we can mock we can test so on and so
forth
all right so this is it this is a pretty
simple service
here is a little bit more complicated
service when creating a course i need to
generate wix
so this is the right place to do it a
bunch of codes can be tested we'll talk
about testing
in a minute and the rule of thumb is
that every non-trivial operation that
touches
the database should be done in service
it's like you should have no orm code
in your api in
your model properties talk about this in
a second
or anywhere else except your services
and selectors
this is the core that defines how your
software is behaving
and on top of that core you have the
shell
which is django which communicates with
the core
this api to the rest of the world and
this
i should i will probably add a link to
gary bernhardt's
talk about boundaries it's really nice
um he did it on railsconf way back in
the time and this is
actually the thing that we're doing is
inspired by this
by this top all right and
services take care of writing to the
database
selectors other way around take care for
things that needs to be
fetched from the database again
selectors.py
we have let me let me get all the
bullets
they take care of the business logic
when fetching which usually some kind of
filtering
they can call arbitrary services
selectors or tasks
whatever needs to be done and can handle
permissions
filters and so on so permissioning
filtering should be
also happening inside the core and not
on the shell
not from the api of course there are
some
exceptions again which we don't have
time for this
and here's a simple selector
from a project that needed this simple
selector
you you want to list all users for a
specific user for specifically logged in
user
which is called fetch by but there are
restrictions from the business from the
domain
about what you can actually see
and the the
this code was firstly written in a get
of an api
and it was not really scalable because
after this
all other interactions for fetching from
the database
needed some kind of permissioning and
filtering
so selector you say give me the
visible users the id so i can filter by
them
so you don't accidentally see something
that you don't have the permission to
see
and as you can see having a plain python
code just using the jungle ram is much
better than having an api
and then this is like the
asterix star on the
model properties for using business
logic
if your model property is a simple
function on
several of your fields it's good
if your model property starts making
queries
outside of its relations or even with
its relations
and let's say
something like this this is a model
property it
better be a selector because right now
we have business logic we have
not present students is making queries
and the general rule of thumb the
general
thumb here is if you have a model
property
and you just add it in the list api and
you get
m plus one problem it should be a
selector
like this a bit too deep in django but
if you have a property that's make it
and okay
then you're going to say select related
okay this can solve
the problem but if you add a property
which cannot be solved with just select
related
to be to solve the m plus one query
sperm then it should
move to a selector so on our rooftop
and then you're going to ask rado but
what about the apis
we started with the treeline api mode of
you set and now
i'd bet you imagine so some huge apis or
how are our apis are going to look and
the good thing about the our apis
is that they're going to look absolutely
the same
they're going to be five to seven lines
long
and we're going to use zero abstraction
over them
which is actually the same thing that we
achieve with model view sets
but without the abstraction so there's
no hidden
or complex and the thing that we achieve
with the apis
is this repeatable pattern because if
you open or pick a random api in a
project that follows strictly this
it's going to look the same you're not
going to be surprised or
if you are surprised then there is a
good exception to everything and there
should be a good comment why
this is a good exception from everything
and you
suddenly see the boundaries between
things and you suddenly start to
navigate the code base much better
because you know what to expect
this is why you use frameworks for all
right
so let's make a course groot
api first we have the list api
we'll talk about why we define
serializers inside
in a minute we have a get with the
selector
we use the serializer to transform the
result to
something that's json serializable and
we return
three lines that's all nothing more
nothing less
detail happy all right
we have get but with course id
we use selector which will probably
fetch
or the other thing that we can do here
is to use
an input serializer that's using primary
key related field that's going to fetch
this course id for us there are like
nuances and options
here but we go selector and we return
and all list and get apis they look
like this you can call generate them if
you will
there's nothing in this api that's
actually hidden or complex
it's a stupid thing that calls selector
again create api we need to create
objects in our system
for list and detail we defined output
serializers
for create and update we define
input serializers and what we do
get the serializer validated
we probably need some additional mix
scenes
to catch validation error and through
no this won't result in a 500 this is
actually okay because it comes from rest
framework
never mind uh we call uh create course
service
which usually just duplicates the
serializers as keyword arguments so i
can just
expand it with two stars and then return
whatever i want
created so on 10 minutes remaining thank
you
and finally an update
api which looks basically like create
and detail we use update courses
service and we use input serializer
again
and this is for me is also neat
but it's neater than the the other thing
because there's no hidden abstraction
there's no additional knowledge of the
framework that you need to have
and let's talk about the elephant in the
room
which is not me it's the serializers
nest our serializers inside the api and
we do this because
otherwise it's really easy to reuse
serializers
i really can't say this word serializers
all right
and if you review serializers then
someone can
add or remove something from a base
serializer that's
inherited five times down the road and
break
who knows how many apis which if you
don't have a good integration test
coverage
the users will catch it it's the user
driven development
where they do the final testing so we
try to inline serializers
and uh
yep and try to not reuse them it's like
you have you need
a good reason to reuse and we still we
still haven't figured out how to freeze
a serializer that's being reduced it's
like you're reusing it but you cannot
modify it anymore because you're going
to break apis
and this happened way too many times and
that's why we started doing it
we have a rule of thumb which says for
output serializers
it's okay to use model serializer
sometimes it saves lines of code
but for input serializers it's strictly
forbidden
you don't use model serializer because
this
kind of says let the model serializer do
the creating no
it's a plain serializer and you define
all the fields that you need
no model serializers there and this
saves a lot of problems and a lot of
headaches
this simple rooftop
and to avoid reusing sometimes uh you
you kind of want to have like in ruby
anonymous classes uh in python in order
just to create in place
an anonymous class which uh extends a
serializer and i can define a few fields
sadly we don't have the syntax but we
have the tools to do it
so we we have this really neat utility
method called inline serializer which
takes
all the keywords for a serializer and
defines the fields
as a dictionary and then there is no
need to reuse a weak serial
serializer defined elsewhere you can
just do it here
in place in line
i don't know i've put the implementation
here it just creates a new
type from the base serializer in the
resources to this presentation there is
the code for this
it's pretty neat it's pretty neat to use
it
and to end everything let's talk about
testing
because it's really important when we do
this service selector thing
the core and the shell testing models
comes down to testing the properties and
testing the clean method
and oftentimes testing properties that
are functions
on fields you don't have to instantiate
models
fast tests good tests also clean you
don't have to instantiate
you don't have to instantiate models if
your clean method just
uses fields some
set of the fields and do something
around them which is really nice
testing services and selectors this is
the heavy lifting
this is where you actually hit the
database you use a lot of
you use a lot of mocking because you use
isolate different parts for example
you've tested this service a lot and you
want to test just the integration
between four services you mock the
services that you've tested or you mock
the email sending that we've done three
times
to randomly fake generated emails uh
you use a lot of mocking here and it's
like the heavy lifting's done here
your brain capabilities go here
and testing kpis there's
with this approach there's usually no
need to test apis because they're just
an interface
and it's usually delegated to
integration tests five minutes remaining
right
usually dedicated to one of my last
slides
delegated to integration testing
which is also really nice but
my talk's not about testing if you want
to hear more about django testing and
what approaches we use you can listen to
martin who is here
uh in lemur
well how do you pronounce this lemon
mirror all right
in this hole it's six at 405.
all right so to recap and to finish
avoid business logic in model safe
method
forms any kind of forms in any kind of
serializers
just don't do it again views and apis
there's no need to do there
business logic and templates tax and
utility methods
utility methods should work like like
pure functions
on pure python data structures on python
data structures
you should not have a utility which
speaks your domain
or if you have it don't call it a
utility just create a simple function
with
leading underscore and don't use it
elsewhere so utilities should not
be doing business logic again tasks
tasks is an interesting topic sometimes
you have to do it
i don't have the time for this sorry
selectors and services again use
services for creating update actions
use selectors for list and detail
actions it's it's really it's really
simple approach but it pays a lot in the
long run
in the long run uh there's more to it
i've just published this morning the
style guide because we have it
internally
and we're going to update it a lot so
i'm going to
tweet it add it to the presentation it's
already added
and so on in case you're interested how
we're doing this
uh again i'm not saying this is the best
way to write django because there are
many ways that are actually valid and
you can build software with them
this is just the way that's working for
us and it's working from experience it's
working from shipping
software that's being used by a lot of
users every day
and we have to be flexible with features
so that's it thanks